votre vidéo vous est présenté par
victoria tirer talents.com vous avez
plus de 5000 follower sur vos réseaux
sociaux
venez nous rejoindre et devenez
influenceurs grâce à victoria tirer
talents.com
[Musique]
on est sur ces 8 on est en direct qui
chante ça m'a tout de la bonne image d
un match défi sera avec nous demain ce
sera la parité mhd il y aura également
miss france oui on pourra demander si
effectivement c'est un ami de vous
inquiéter
il nous a dit que c'était son ami au
monde en salle de bain vous inquiétez
pas mhd sera avec nous et ça nous rend
jaloux qu'est ce qu'il reste du monde
avec des gens s'intéressent à htc votre
avis on est au studio on est potes
1 comment vous la plus belle je
l'appelle mhd par son nom de scène mais
je sais travailler c'est pas dans lequel
je sais que ses passes ont annoncé les
studios presse ebra ses initiales
c'est quoi son nom alors mouloud
[Rires]
[Musique]
moi je suis là julia étant donné que
exceptionnellement notre imitateur n'est
pas là cette semaine à huy fabian le
castel voilà qu'on embrasse chacun va
faire une imitation car le mardi c'est
le jour de l'est mais là d'ailleurs
merci oui eh bien je la conduis on vous
écoute mais au début quand vous avez dit
'tiens je pensais que c'était beau qu'on
ait l'air con mais je sens qu'ils
marchent artistique derrière vraiment là
il faut être bon c'est toby booth et
c'est un truc que je maîtrise
parfaitement ainsi le concert c'est
isabelle morini-bosc annoncé pierre
panaccio jays peña cloche le faire mais
m'est venue quand vous avez demandé
merci d'avoir suivi cette émission salut
les trucs n'est pas si mauvais mais
c'est quelque chose un petit truc s'est
introduit sa veut dire que ça lui on
n'est pas dans une de vos soirées
[Applaudissements]
oh là où à l'instar des saltos dos a dit
oui moi je la force
bonjour c'est qu'ici c'est enrique je
trouvais l'accent la presse une liste
elle ça pour elle à qui donc j'ai fait
la démarche
c'est la nouvelle technique des
imitateurs il paraît très bien merci non
mais ça veut dire que là si enrique
iglesias ne regarde se retourne dans sa
tombe
or notre on clique valérie le fait mieux
que faire alors donc le ciel jeudi c'est
un [ __ ] cgc qui passe et patrick
sébastien et le majeur en fait on va
vous venez faire et le majeur sur la
suite de ça lui laisse couler
tu merdé moi je n'attendais on va s'est
trouvé qu'il s'agissait de trouver dans
ces saillies chez vous c'est nous la
pala nous promet trois taxes on reprend
tout plu à laisser partir de demain
bonjour je viens de loin je suis heureux
d'être là avec vous ce soir jean marc
généreux
non non c'est pas vrai pas trouvé c'est
qui or à telus nous avons fait
exactement elle c'est oui bravo mme dion
alesis pas si vos fins est donné ce soir
j'avais là-bas vous présenter à la vie à
voir ses charges là bas allez il
s'appelle morini-bosc visiter notre
belle mais aulas michael jackson n'est
pas dingue ce matin à tours et certains
ont même fait leur vie privée c'est pas
mal être ou des serviettes très bien
j'habite tout seul avec maman de trevi
appartient ou ses réserves pour me tenir
compagnie d'une tortue de canaris le
fait bien monsieur arrêtez vous avez
prêté le savez il a la main qui tremble
un peu cher et moi mon genre la main qui
tremble un peu
merci maintien de leur mort
[Applaudissements]